what do we need to know about the father
of all [ __ ] when we perform
this what are we saying god I think it's
like a combination of its it's kind of a
political but it also kind of deals in
sort of depression and I mean the first
time I've ever written about money so
it's like there's the line lying in a
bed of blood and money what are your
feelings toward money I mean you
obviously have a lot of it I think you
know it's sort of mixed emotions about
it like it's a are you a very the
imposter syndrome or something like that
like you don't deserve it
well I you know we come from such broke
backgrounds that is just sort of you
know for me it's like you know my dad
was a truck driver and my brother's a
plumber my my other brother worked as a
custodian and stuff like that so it's
just very working-class background and
to have work compared to when I had not
it was it's just been it's sort of a
trip so we gonna do this song yeah
Brandon I do you know all the lyrics I
think so I mean if you guys rehearse it
I we don't wanna alright from the new
album this is the title track and I'll
shut my mouth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
beautiful